[Music]
joining me today is a national security
expert the best-selling author of
defeating jihad and a former albeit
brief strategist to President Trump
dr. Sebastian Gorka welcome to the Rubin
report thanks Lambie baby
I'm happy to have you here sir first off
that voice you have a very have you ever
done any voiceover work at all it's
don't tell anybody but it's my dream
when I wrote defeating jihad and I asked
about the audio book I said I'm gonna
get to do the audio book write to my
publisher you can do the prologue then
we'll get a pro I was crushed right so
the next book coming out in June why we
fight I'm sorry if you're listening
Margie I'm doing it was over so I really
can't believe that so first up we have
already spent a good amount of time
talking about Star Wars
I am very impressed your greenroom and
that post I'd never seen that McQuarrie
poster before yeah I'm the LP so I'm
impressed that is the original 1977
poster I wonder do you think because
we're obviously to talk a lot about
national security and foreign policy and
all that do you think any of your
thoughts related to foreign policy have
anything to do with Star Wars because I
do think at some level some of the way I
view the world has been shaped by some
of the lore and oh yeah I'm not sure if
it's cause and effect but but absolutely
in terms of good and evil I mean totally
I mean the first three movies are about
good versus evil before they become this
social justice warrior absurdity so yes
sure I mean but as much as being the son
of people who lived under Nazi and then
communist dictatorship these things kind
of flowed together so Star Wars and
growing up under the child of people
escaped from dictation right there yeah
all right so you are in California
because you were talking to a couple
conservative groups here in California
people don't believe that conservative
groups could exist in California but I
mentioned to you before we just had
Governor John Kasich on he was talking
with Arnold Schwarzenegger at some
conservative groups here in California
so there it seems like something is
happening in California I don't live
here
but I come in and out to do
these events something's happening so
something clearly is happening the
energy I felt that the the events here
is is like the energy I feel at events
in Virginia or elsewhere like Texas and
there's a commonality whoever you speak
to they keep mentioning the same things
that they talk about the gas tax they
talk about sang free cities they talk
about the burden on businesses when you
get these things repeated enough times
you realize something is happening in
California who knows where it'll go but
this this isn't the state you know I
used to say you know the People's
Republic just lost forever I'm not so
sure anymore
really so do you think this could be
something that could happen as soon as
our next our gubernatorial election
that's coming up now or do you think
this is sort of long term maybe
presidential election 2020 year all I'll
say is the following with the election
of Donald J Trump to president the
political rule book has been shredded
burnt buried and the Donald Trump jumped
up and down on it it's gone so any past
expectations any trend lines are
irrelevant I mean I traveled with the
president
- we flew on Air Force One to Youngstown
Ohio back in June and this is steel
Valley right this is the heart of a
blue-collar Democrat manual laborers and
we we arrived at the stadium and the
president was in the back I was you know
doing selfies with you know the crowd I
do love the crowd selfie I've seen many
problems what does it cost me they want
a selfie yes sure why not yeah so I got
to engage with these people and I
realized that in this stadium about
twenty twenty-five thousand people
everybody was either a former registered
Democrat their parents their
grandparents or all Democrats and then
what happens when the president when the
first lady Melania comes out of the
stage it erupts the building erupts with
chants of the USA drain the swamp and
this is democrat territory now if that
can happen in youngster now we
Youngstown Ohio
who knows what can happen in California
yeah so I want to talk a little bit
about your history and your parents and
growing up that I just mentioned but as
long as we're on the on the first part
of the Trump portion of this let's just
keep doing that I heard you at the
turning point USA event in December give
a speech which I really thought was
wonderful and you described Trump as the
ice breaker and what I've been saying
around here is that I view him as the
bull in the china shop we wanted a
panther to knock over a few things but
we got the bull and I think that really
it's really the same analogy that we're
using there so can you just yeah I don't
further on that a little bit so the
United States was covered for at least
30 years in this massive permafrost
layer of ice which is political
correctness and it had frozen over the
media education politics all of it to
the extent that by the Obama
administration federal government was
telling you who could use which bathroom
right so just insanity and then along
comes a guy who the first day I met him
in summer of June 15 in his office in
Trump Tower the first thing I knew about
this man is he's the Kryptonite of
political correctness and he couldn't
care less about what the New York Times
or CNN says about a given issue so along
comes this man layer of ice frozen over
the country BAM slams into it like an
ice breaker and smashes through the ice
so he breaks a pathway for for the
nation to to open up that sea Lane and
and my argument to conservative
audiences is that this is great this is
monumental it wasn't going to be the
path the path that could never have won
it had to be the ball it had to be the
Icebreaker
but if you know your physics of ice
breaking you can send that you know
thousands of tons worth of ship in there
with its tungsten how rides up on the
ice slices through it
but if you don't have the flotilla
behind it that comes up and keeps that
passageway open what actually happens in
real life is if you send one ship in
breaks a path almost instantaneously the
ice comes around the bow andreen it's
it's off right around the ship and
reseals so this is the moment in the
conservative movement well we have to
get serious of about what does it mean
to be a conservative in the 21st century
what's the role of government how does a
national security look
so on and so forth Donald Trump is the
catalyst now we have to do the heavy
lifting of ideology and politics and
policy yeah do you think he will years
from now when we look back be anything
other than the catalyst like how do you
how do you consider his ideas compared
to traditionally conservative ideas
because just in the last couple months
after signing the omnibus thing you know
right now when we're take we're taping
this a few days before we're gonna air
it but there's a big mess in Syria we're
not sure you know if there's gonna be
more intervention or not he seems to be
doing some things that are probably a
little more big government than perhaps
you want Horst certainly then his base
seems to want so where do you think he
fits actually between catalyst and the
end the flotilla so first things first
I hate labels personally IIIi think
labels is lazy thinking and in the case
of Donald Trump very relevant and then
they have no application our credit
monitor Cattrall in my friend with this
the weekend after the election was david
horowitz's was it a restoration weekend
yeah in Florida yeah which was either
going to be awake or the party that was
and Monica gave a great speech in which
he said look everybody misunderstands
who this man is he was never an
ideological candidate because you simply
cannot put him in a box because of what
he does whether it's his attitude to gay
marriage whether it's it's just he's
what he's just a mixture he was never an
ideological candidate he was an
attitudinal candidate and she nailed it
now what does that mean look at the last
40 years this guy's 71 years old he's
not going to change he is who he is
what has he done for the last 40 years
as a professional he's been committed to
one thing excellence whether it's a golf
course in Scotland whether it's a
skyscraper in New York its excellence
and all he's done is he's taken that
concept and tried you know translated it
into excellence for America once more
and that doesn't fit into neat
neoliberal neocon paleo corn it just
doesn't fit he's about getting stuff
done and being the best but so how do
you link that to what the general
conservative movement is now I get I get
what you're saying about labels and I
say it all
the labels now especially because of
Trump the labels are all the brothers at
this point but the thing that I'm
struggling to fully grasp about the
Trump thing is how does this connect to
you know when I see you right now you
have a huge split right we've got the
the Trump base and then you've got the
never Trump errs and these people are
that should be kind of lining up they
can't quite get there
and how do you connect those things like
how do you connect what like that the
never Trump is a pathological I mean
pathological when when Bill Kristol you
know who's all obsequious and oleaginous
to me in the green room at Fox when he
tweets out actually tweets out in a
choice between the deep state and
president Trump I choose the deep state
yeah you're not a conservative
you're a subversive right get out of the
tent get out of the tent so that's never
going to happen
the broader question of what is
conserved you mean today we can't answer
that because have you seen a good
article a really good article which
understands first principles founding
principles about what Trump ism is or
should be I haven't I've seen a lot of
people who think they know what they're
talking about but who've never met the
president so I think there's a lot of
work to be done but it's not going to be
done by conservative establishment
individuals if the NRA is not going to
tell you who Trump is right and the
Inara is not going to revitalize the
conservative establishment right this is
a new year it's exciting but we have to
get to work to define what it means to
be a conservative so that to me is why
it seems so obvious that you're so
passionate about this that nobody else
was going to do it and I think that's
also that's sort of what Monica was
saying and it's sort of what Horowitz
has been saying for a long time even
when he sat right there that no one else
was gonna break through and now it's
imperfect but at least there's me you
know be brutally candid you know I grew
up in the UK to Hungarian parents of
escape communism I went through the the
private school system in the UK stiff
upper lip and all that stuff and a
debating Club so the president's style
is not exactly the style I'm used to
right I get to get used to it and I
understand with people of issues the
biggest people biggest
people have issues with on the right I
his tweets I get it
but guess what who was glad to defeat
Hillary wasn't Jeb Bush yeah wasn't even
senator Cruz none of them were going to
the only person who could cut through
that miasma who could break through the
ice of political correctness was this
rank outsider from Manhattan and whether
you like it or not he to say for Asafa
Kalihi was the necessary but not
sufficient cause of victory you don't
have to like it but it had to be him
with that start we tried to do Marquess
of Queensbury rules for 30 years where
did it get us where did it get us Mitt
Romney wrong guys right so it had to be
Donald Trump now we have to backfill
what it means yeah and that seems to be
where I think you and so many of these
other people that are either part or
formerly part of the administration so
you had a very brief stint at the
administration first of all even some
look right years from now they'll go my
god he was there for longer than
everybody else but a pretty brief stint
7 months first can you just tell me how
you got involved because you had only
you just mentioned you only met him a
little bit before the election in the
first place and then and then sort of
what happened that had you leave because
that rule really tie into the media
which I think were very much aligned on
what's going on with the media right now
so a summer of 15 I get a phone call
from a guy called corey levin dosti that
i'd never heard of and he said candidate
Trump is prepping for the big full GOP
presidential debate on national security
he'd like to talk to you said sure so I
took the plane flew to New York went to
Trump Tower it was just the three of us
in Donald Trump's office and we had this
incredible blue sky discussion on
national security issues you name it
from the Civil War up to the middle east
and nuclear weapons all kinds of topics
how knowledgeable did he seem about
things because this is one of the parts
that I think people we have no handle on
like does he really
really interested yeah but not a guy
that you're gonna debate what happened
in Karbala in the ninth century but but
but really interested in this stuff and
with opinions and and half way through
this discussion and he was sitting
closer to me than you are and qualities
over here and he there's a classic
trumpism he goes just stops the
conversation Cory I like this guy
let's hire him and that was it and he
asked me to help right it wasn't part of
the campaign but I became an advisor
wrote policy papers that he used in the
briefings and and we stayed in touch but
I never joined the campaign and then as
things progressed and he the field
whittled down to what it did I kept
meeting general Flynn at events I was a
participant just in the crowd I kept
bumping into general Flynn and I'd known
him from when he was director to dia and
eventually we just he pulled me in and
by October the month before the election
I know if you're familiar with the
system and in the presidential election
the last two runners get support from
the federal government before the
election and they get offices near the
White House to create transition teams
to prep and so Hillary got one story and
and the president got another story this
building and I was pulled into the pen
hilarious it's in the same building oh
yeah and you cut if you talk in the
elevator right so I got pulled in and
asked to work on the National Security
Council transition team for general
Flynn and my wife who has a background
in the issues was pulled in to work on
the DHS team and so I became part of the
official transition team and up till the
very last moment the week before you
know maybe the week of the inauguration
I was going to be doing counterterrorism
stuff for general Flynn in the NFC and
then Steve Madden who knows me yeah
reaches out in the last minutes of new
they're gonna come work for me and the
office of the chief strategist is
strategist to the president and that's
how you know at 12:01 on Johnny xx I
became a deputy assistant to the
president
yeah so the second that happened
basically the media just went bananas on
you I mean every store I mentioned to
you that right no no the act when they
went bananas was it even before that
it's very interesting they didn't they
didn't go bananas until the the travel
ban dropped and I realized things were
not going well in terms of communicating
the travel ban mm-hmm so I said to Steve
and I said to Sean guys I've done a bit
of media in the past I can be the face
of this stuff if you want I mean we've
got the NFC communications team but I'm
prepared to go and CNN and debate these
guys and so they threw me into the the
you know the the fire and I loved it and
the left went nuts they're just
absolutely worth insane yeah and it was
what once I was very representing the
president on television that out came
the hit pieces and the lights yeah so
let's talk about that a little bit
because I see this happening to almost
everyone that I have any degree of
respect for I see it happen I see it
it's coming it's coming to me now too I
mean I see this to almost anyone that I
think is trying to be somewhat honest
yeah the endless attacks I mean you know
there were just a endless slew of things
that you're an anti-semite and all of
this craziness I mean at the turning
point event that I saw you speak at you
get one of the strongest defenses of
Israel that I've ever heard but they
almost take everything and do the
complete reverse of it
what do you make of that tactic
specifically where it's literally the
reverse of what the truth is it's not
just like we're gonna take a line and
make it seem a little different we're a
new sign that's absolutely you know
you've got a big viewership i I know
you're why I'm no longer a progressive
thing is got ya having millions of views
now and and I'll open up a little bit
despite the size of your audience um I
have a reputation for being a scary dude
and being a hard-ass that's fine but
after the seven months that I went
through and my family went through every
time every few weeks I have the same
emotional response and it probably
surprises your others as a human being I
want to try and understand how another
human being
who's never met me who knows nothing
about me or what my family has been
through can write what they wrote about
me will say what they say about me it
leaves me speechless that you can have
such venomous hatred for somebody and
pedals so egregious sets of lives and
and you not only call yourself a
journalist but you actually think you're
a human being I was attacked
and that's fine because I'm a
politically commissioned officer of the
President I'm a proxy I was a proxy for
Steve I was a proxy for the president I
understand that that's okay but hey why
don't we debate the policies they never
wanted to never wanted to bait the
policies it was ad hominem attacks and
lives and secondly it's okay to attack
me but guess what
sort of can't attack my wife it's not
okay to attack my dead mother's
reputation and it's not a kid attack my
teenage high school-aged son either
these people are reprehensible and
they're out of control David and they're
not learning that doubling down so
that's the part that I'm concerned about
right now that it see people always ask
me I did an event in Irvine last night
and and the question I'm getting more
and more now is is this thing turning
around now I sense my sense is that
there is something brewing against it
there's something brewing finally and I
think any of us in this space are a
little piece of it but to me it's gonna
get a lot worse before it gets better
and that that's what I'm concerned about
you're nodding already so I suspect you
I think you're right
under what conditions does something
like that change if we rule out violence
right we don't want to have violence
okay we've you know the the worst war we
ever had was our Civil War okay 600,000
Americans killed even though they're
subtly condoning violence eeo of
twitter's condoning it so let's that's
you know pray to the good Lord that
that's that's not where we're going
what's the other op
what's the other scenario that they look
in the mirror and they stop but why
would they they reward each other for
the lies and we look at Time Magazine's
latest issue it's just a farrago of lies
it's all opinion pieces not journalism
when they look at the people who they
celebrate at their get-togethers they're
not journalists I mean there's maybe six
journalists left in this country that
are actually doing investigative
research like Sara cada right like Molly
Hemingway when are they going to be
recognized by the Washington press corps
never never because they don't comport
with the narrative that we're Nazis and
the president is a dictator this is a
man whose grandchildren are Orthodox
Jews can you wrap your heads around it
New York Times CNN Huffington Post
BuzzFeed you're reprehensible for
calling this administration what you
call it I know the press he doesn't not
that he doesn't have a racist bone in
his body he doesn't have a racist
molecule in his body the stunning thing
I mean this is this is what why it was
such an honor to work for him the
stunning thing about Donald Trump is and
look I got a Bible in my pocket I can
swear on it I'll swear on this Bible
this man wants only two things for all
Americans he wants you and your family
to be safe and he wants you to prosper
which is what all of prep America of
American president should want but you
know it's stunning David he wants that
for you whether or not you voted for him
or not hmm
he doesn't care whether you voted for
her he doesn't care whether you wanted
Bernie for him he doesn't care whether
you stayed at home and ate Doritos
if you're an American living here
legally he wants you to be safe from
harm from gangs from terrorism and he
wants you to prosper like he has
prospered and the left this is the
answer to your question the left will
never ever believe that although it is
true and I tested it so when they put
you out there and as you said you use or
I got it all no no no that that that's
what it's all about right
that's what it's all about what you just
said there when they put you out there
and as you said you willfully went out
to go for the for the ban the Muslim ban
all right wouldn't we talked about it on
the show a moratorium but right okay but
I'm going forward to their narrative
okay so we talked about it a bunch on
the show I did a bunch of videos I tried
to be very fair I have Muslim friends
I've had Muslims on the show and X
Muslims and I've had people that are
critical religion and people that are
religious on the whole freaking thing
look most of the countries the most of
the most populous countries of Muslim
people were not included on the band the
original list was Obama by the Obama
ministration all that so I tried to talk
about it as fairly as possible but it
seems to be one of those issues and then
I think this will sort of lead us a
little bit into your book as well
talking about radical Islam and trying
to just you know make the distinction
between Islam as a set of ideas versus
Muslims as people and of course you
shouldn't be prejudiced and all of that
this seems to be basically the stickiest
thing that we have going right now right
like that like it's just quicksand to
even talk about it
you mean the threat of jihadism well
just I mean the kind of things that are
so well the core the quicksand of trying
to make the distinction of we have to be
able to talk about ideas and we have to
fight for good ideas and against bad
ideas but at the same time make sure
that we're not being prejudiced towards
people and making sure that America
remains the open plurals pluralistic
society that it is look the argument in
my book differing jihad is a very simple
one we live in the only country ever
created on the principle of individual
freedom and liberties and granted to us
not by the government but by our Creator
because we are made in His image that
the founding father said you are you
have dignity because you are made in the
image of the creator not because
Washington says you have dignity and
that concept of the individual's dignity
and the freedom that it provides is
antithetical to the spectrum of politics
that says man is perfectible and
perfection can be created in real my
first degree was philosophy and theology
and I study at this event here in
in California all politics can be
conveyed all ideological differences can
be summarized in just two camps it
doesn't matter which country you're in
or what era two camps those that believe
truth is objective and not man-made and
those who say no man can define truth
and perfection can be created here on
earth
this statement that man defines truth
leads to the gas chambers and to the
gulags okay now social justice warriors
don't realize that they're walking down
the same path but it's the same concept
to say I'm going to perfect the world
and there will be justice and equality
no you won't if we are free there will
never be justice for all and equality
for all as long as we are free because
evil is real evil exists man is fallen
and jihadism is just the latest version
like my book is a very simple argument
there's a connective tissue between our
Qaeda and Isis and the Nazis of the
Third Reich and the Communists of the
Soviet Union yes they worship different
things wrong worship an Aryan race one
which should work in class the other
worship their version of Islam but guess
what the connective tissue is they're
all totalitarian and if you disagree
with them guess what yeah you're going
to be enslaved or murdered end of story
and if you if you deny that reality and
I I've trained six seven thousand
federal officers I've trained more than
that in the military when a military
professional an FBI agent understands
that his government is telling him what
he can or cannot say about the threat
group he's supposed to be protecting us
from then we have problems when
President Obama says in 2011 write a
memo to the chair of the Joint Chiefs
and the then Attorney General all
characters and training of FBI agents
and the US military must not mention
Islam and especially must not mention
the word jihad mm-hmm well that's like
saying we're about to storm the Normandy
beaches and guys make sure you're em
one's loaded and your boots are tied up
but whatever you do don't mention the
word Nazi because you could offend a
German it's a bad SNL skit David now
it's insanity and the
that we weren't allowed to talk about it
truthfully that gets people killed
political correctness eventually can
lead to good people dying yeah
so that also explains why there's such
craziness in Europe right now right I
mean we're gonna see it seems to me that
we're gonna consistently see the rise of
right or far-right parties but it really
is just the symptom of not being able to
talk about these issues honestly let's
differentiate between the rise of two
different things okay
so we've just an election Hungary we've
seen the elections in Italy announced
when we seen brexit let's not conflate
two issues
there's the rise of very disturbing
groups like your bikini Hungary there
are really crypto nationalists and and
and feed off a long seeded anti-semitic
kind of irredentist sentiment in the
country so these are the true sort of
they're not all white nationalist but
the true sort of they want ethno states
and they want right like well it's
complicated because there's history
there this Trianon is varisai but
they're bigots yeah the bigots okay then
that you mustn't conflate that with the
Trump phenomena and things like brexit
its original causation and I don't even
use the word populism I reject the word
populism unless your definition is part
of populism is those kinds of politics
that the elite disagrees with I'm pretty
sure that's not the standard right
initially for me this isn't populism the
Trump winning or brexit happening this
is a reassertion of democracy
I mean why did Trump occur because
people on the left and the right looked
at DC and said you know I don't know the
difference between Sunni and Shia but
guess what it's broken I don't know what
a federal budget should look like but
we're spending like drunken sailors so
it's the reassertion of accountable
politics Vice faceless bureaucracy or
uni party swamp dwellers whether they're
in DC or whether they're in Brussels so
for me it should be what we should
welcome it with open arms this is a
reassertion of accountable government
but for the left that wants uniformity
of thought and bigger government it's
fascism
all right so how does the hata then does
the right how do you police that I know
that you don't like that idea of
policing and government coming to fix it
but how do you make sure that the part
that you're worried about doesn't lead
the good part because I think from the
way at least from the way I see it the
left is always led now by its worst part
then that's why they purge everybody the
video that you mentioned that I did I'm
Prager you that's what I talked about I
mean anyone that steps out of group
think you get purged and that's why I
think there's such a movement towards
libertarianism or classical liberalism
or whatever you like God so I see what
the left is doing on that how do you
make sure that doesn't happen on the
right where the far right that you were
worried about yeah you think it's a fair
estimation to call it far right and yeah
yeah I don't even like the word all
right
yeah it's bogus I think those are just
that's a new label for nationalists or
or irredentist bigots yeah all right
that's a real yeah they're rewrapping
themselves to be some fake to be fit for
polite you know company well I hate to
tell you racist I hate to tell you on
your Wikipedia page you cause you all
right of course I said right and I've
said you know that the page that doesn't
allow the subject to correct yeah right
when I try and correct the lies it's
frozen interesting Wikipedia your I told
you right before we started but your
Wikipedia out of all of the ones that
cuz I usually just glanced they're not
out of fact but just to get a sense of
what's going on yours is such a mess
it's I've tried I've tried to correct
the friends who tried to correct it then
they froze it and then forget about it
yeah so what do you do those you write
those two things don't come we need a
spine so those of us that have a podium
those that are out there those that that
wish to see the principles we believe in
in terms of the founding come back and
be celebrating this country we have to
call them out like we don't believe that
you use legislation I mean hate speech
give me a break
I mean either you're inciting violence
or you're not either you're committing a
crime or you're not we don't need extra
labels and we don't need censorship call
them out for what they are we need
people on the right who say you know
what he's a racist that all right think
that's just bigotry that's just the KKK
wrapped up in a new you know Bo it's up
to us yeah do you think they're laughing
that's not gonna do it right they're
gonna use it they only use those people
to decide
the majority do you think that we're not
enough no not enough by far we have
begun but there's a lot of work to do
yeah
does everything that's happening in
Europe right now and there's definitely
a distinction to be made between what's
happening in Eastern Europe versus
Western Europe and Eastern Europe I
think is dealing with some of their
existential crises he's a little bit
better perhaps because Western Europe
still a little behind on the political
correctness stuff that you're talking
about does everything that's happening
in Europe right now does it all come
down to immigration do you think no no
no immigration was the blue touch paper
or on the fire work
no it's it's the death of the
representative democracy I mean I
watched this because I grew up in the UK
under Margaret Thatcher for me Maggie
the Gipper Blessed Saint John Paul the
second these are my heroes and I
remember riding to school on the bus in
the morning in West London and the bus
driver would be Jamaican I did with my
Indian or Pakistani school buddy I read
this Polish guy next to me I mean it's
super her Trojan is part of London and
that's right as far as I was concerned
these are all Brits the guy must have
might have had a thickest Jamaican
accent possible like my friend Martin's
mom cook the best in Indian curries but
guess what we're all British yeah that's
gone you know what Tony Blair came in
when Clinton came in this idea that you
know the West is guilty and words like
British are pejorative you're a good
jarate you're Welsh or whatever that was
the death of these countries I mean why
do you think I'm in America I'm a proud
American citizen now because we they
lost the plot the things that the G is
that the fought for that the Tommies
fought for it's safe spaces really your
19 year olds and being blown up over
Berlin in bomber planes and you want a
safe space this is in a space of 70
years I mean what's going on in London
right now
this is the land of Churchill yeah it's
shocking so I saw I'm sure you saw this
but just in the last couple weeks they
said London's crime violent crime has
now surpassed New York City's for the
first time in history and then Sadiq
Khan who's the mayor a statement saying
you can't carry knives I mean first off
people are walking on with switzer Army
knives a woman that might want to
protect herself might want to have a
knife in her pocket I mean you know it
seems like a mass mental disorder to me
but that's what happens that is the
natural progression when you deny
objective truth if everything is plastic
then you will get wrapped around your
own axle in absurdities and for for a
mayor of one of the most powerful cities
in the world a financial sense to say no
one should ever have a knife on them and
nobody needs a knife so every plumber
every tradesman every person looking at
a fish market is suddenly out of a job
Sadiq Khan you're insane so what does
your Britain or Europe in a wider sense
have to do to reverse the tide on some
of this stuff I mean like Nigel Farage I
don't know I mean it's look at this
saying it crops up in every nation every
country deserves the politicians they
elect don't alone get out there
well I see where I live outside DC I
mean you're the Conservatives who's so
fed up and they're constantly posting
stuff on Facebook what have you done to
do something about it have you gone out
with leaflets have you given more than
five dollars to your local candidate
have you given up and surrendered I see
this all the time that people who say
well greatest nation on earth and then
they say well you know we're going
purple and so many bureaucrats moved in
and what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do would you have said that in
1776 but the founding fathers have said
what are you gonna do no is this just a
symptom of the success of the West that
we've just become so successful that
you're right we kind of sit there and we
sit on Twitter and we complain all day
but we're all talking we're not doing
anything like it's all talk it's not due
it's it's much more than that it's deep
I mean III
went to the Jesuits I studied philosophy
under them it was painful but I will I
won't regret a minute of it identity is
a function of history and culture and
values and if if you don't study Western
civilization in your schools in your
colleges this is what happens if you
don't understand why people have dignity
just that they do Oh unless they're
conservatives right this is where you
arrive at and and you know who's
responsible for this I don't blame the
left David right this is not the day
this is not the left your capability
it's ours it's the conservatives the
radicals when they saw Paris in fire in
1968 believed that they could do the
same in America that we could have a
left-wing revolution this is what your
students were democratic society
believed and when Bernardine Dohrn and
Bill Ayers took over the SDS and tried
to execute the Chicago days of Rage what
happened because Americans are not
rabble rousing leftists it died it was a
damp squib
optica their Maoist revolution the what
was it the prairie fire manifesto died
instantly
so what did they decide I'd read that
Trotsky they'd rather let him a even you
a Hitler said give me their children and
I'll own their future so these people
actually became tenured professors in
Chicago they became high school teachers
and what did we do on the right we left
them people who avowedly believe America
is evil were allowed to influence our
education system to the point at which
they pretty much owned it but with
exception of your Hillsdale and Grove
City they are in the education system
and and what was our response home
schooling great I love the movement but
you're not gonna save my daddy
that's not very enough yeah so it's
gonna be a hard slog it's gonna be
twenty thirty years of saying guys
America means this and it's nothing to
do with your skin color it's nothing
through your sexual preference your
social class your gender America is
eternal values and that's that's going
to be a lot of work
[Music]
you